very soon we will all be getting
together and celebrating the
Thanksgiving season with friends and
family and one of the best feelings is
knowing that from top to bottom your
carpet Talent grout upholstery even your
air ducts have been professionally
cleaned by our friends at Zerorez and
Ben McKee from Zerorez the sponsors of
this next segment along with Doug and
they're here to help remind us that you
need to call and make those appointments
today am I right this is the day we're
gonna get booked up so give us a call
and we'll get you a place spotless for
you it really does make a difference and
you obviously do carpets which we're
going to show you an example of their
work here in a second but one thing I
really want to focus on that's really
important is air quality in your home
and you guys do air ducts too we do our
our whole approach is just improve the
is to improve the indoor air quality of
your home or your business and that
starts out with getting your carpets
cleaned it's the biggest air filter in a
home believe it or not and we could top
it off with cleaning your ductwork with
the greatest and latest technology now
if you make appointment you have to make
two separate appointments one for air
ducts one for carpet or can you do it
all in one visit we could do it all in
one visit whatever is easiest for you
just give us a call and we can answer
those questions for you and figure out
what specifically helps you out it
really does change everything I feel
like I can breathe easier when you guys
come into my home let's show them a
little bit Doug of what we've got going
on here Ben you guys always dirty up
this carpet we do
and let's uh it's called The One swipe
magic uh look at this I know it's it's
magic and it looks like we got Magic
Water this water this is our ZR water
technology that has no soaps no
chemicals no or no harsh chemicals no
surfactants it's just the power of water
and that is amazing to me because it
dries faster because there's no soap
that gets sticky in there and then also
you're protecting your pets and your
kids and anyone else who's in there
definitely I've got two little ones at
home and I'm you know concerned about
what are they crawling on when they're
crawling on the carpets and with zero
res it's completely safe and the best
thing is it's effective you can see the
difference that it makes you mentioned
businesses too businesses can call you
up you can come in there and clean up
absolutely whether you've got convention
space hotels or a little office we can
get you cleaned up let's talk about the
deal that you're going to offer for our
viewers oh it's my holiday season my
favorite time of year so right now you
get three rooms of carpet clean for only
119 and we're gonna throw throw in a
free family pass to the glittering
lights oh that is unheard of love it you
guys always offer the best deals thank
you guys so much dear res you guys are
the best thank you for sponsoring this
segment and take advantage of that
holiday sale again it's three rooms of
carpet clean for only 119 plus that free
family pass to glittering lights the
drive-through lights display at the Las
Vegas Motor Speedway you can call
702-840-333 or go online to
zerorezlasvegas.com for more information
minimums apply